[Music]
[Music]
for me no we're checking on me so i had
to go run up a check i got the message
homie get no flexing on me my attorney
gonna call and collect blessings on
blessing for me my successors only made
them envious they got upset i had to put
all their egos in check i want the money
hey what's happening coming coming guys
so i've had a lot of women asking me
evans can i shadow you for a day
evans can i pick your brain and it's
just so many people so it's almost
impossible to do with everyone so i just
thought it makes sense for me to just
vlog a day in the life of me i hope you
guys enjoy it's going to be an amazing
day stay tuned
i like to listen to you motivational
stuff by eric thomas always kept me
pumped i've been listening to eric
thomas every single morning for the last
year and it just gets me started so
every single day if i fail i have to
listen to the guy himself eating
preacher come on
[Music]
yes literally just about to start my
morning routine i love to start running
um it really helps with my mental health
always keeps me calm always keeping me
sane so wherever i am i have to hit the
gym if there's no gym i go hit the run
so that's what i do every day
there
feeling fresh feeling good it's gonna be
a great day
[Music]
yes guys so literally yesterday i had a
full day of viewings hence the reason
why i crashed in a local uh hotel i'm
now up north i'm about to show you guys
what i'm going to be doing up north
today i'm literally about to hail out
and collect the
collect
keys
keys to a brr joint venture using none
of my own money i'm so pumped guys you
know what i love talking let's get on
the road
[Music]
a pcn ticket that's the sign of you're
gonna have a great day today
you cannot stop this is life
and you can't defeat me
look that's my whole message
it's just gonna take me some time to get
you here yes yes so we're literally on
the motorway right now we're going to
m-60 we're heading down to
um
near bradford area
to collect the keys to uh amazing
property you guys need to stay tuned to
watch
that property so pumped super class
[Applause]
[Music]
i feel pumped man ah this property do
you know what it's been about ten months
you've been going back and forth with
solicitors and agents and stuff like
that and finally it's completion finally
i'm getting the key today
very busy area there's an 80
occupancy rate for service accommodation
in this area so i know it works very
good friend gel spinner she's got hm was
just five minutes walk from here yeah
evans let's get the kids
oh my god
baby i feel pumped man i get the keys
got the keys got the kids got his bad
boy
buying a house buying a property is a
hundred times easier than buying a car
there's no signing there's no paperwork
there's no come in and get coffee
they're just coming
certify your license collect the kids
so welcome to my investment property
come in and have a look
so currently this property is a massive
eight bedroom house that we're going to
be converting into a massive 10 bedroom
hmo so if you look at this this was the
living room what do you think we're
going to put your hair
we're going to put a bed in here and
onto it make it an
ensuite room the plans are not finalized
yet we're still walking around it with
the architect but the plan is to knock
down this wall
all right knock down this wall
and i have a massive open plan
kitchen because it needs to be the right
size right dimensions
look they left some extras
[Music]
okay it's a massive open space hasn't
been used
um and this has got so much potential i
mean you can easily our plan is to knock
this down and actually create
a free
a three bedroom apartment that we're
looking to convert to a service
accommodation i mean look it's got so
much dead space
it's not been used for years
we're currently putting the plants
through
to knock it down
to
um and have bi-folding doors overview in
the garden
which is going to be for a massive
luxury service accommodation put a nice
jacuzzi in there so that's the plans of
course nothing is finalized yet we have
to wait and see but it's just got so
much potential that it hasn't got so
much potential
um i'm super excited for this project i
want to convert to flats but then the
builds cost and the end value of the
flats it just didn't really
it didn't really add up just knock this
down open up the kitchen
you can easily put two bedrooms down
there and it's gonna be a bedroom
you must be a bedroom and you just knock
down this wall
yes i've just collected it thank you so
much for your help
no problem thank you
this work for me is knock this down put
an ensuite in here
and again it's going to be another
massive double room
um you can charge you know up to 450
very good views out there
again you have a massive room
um so my plan is to have a back-to-back
back-to-back toilet
and then we come here
another massive room
this is probably the smallest room in
the house but it's still it still is
a hundred square meters two
three four
five six
seven
oh yeah easily so the whole aim of this
project is to make every single room 100
square meters and 100 square meters
excluding the ensuite because if that
becomes the case i would not need a
communal area by law so that's the plan
just consume as much space as possible
in this property and try and get as many
bedrooms in because every single bedroom
the more bedrooms is the more
is the more money baby
yeah so the architect is literally just
finalizing drawings so i should have
um the draft joins from him um this week
and the official ones next week we're
gonna go go for planning now
it'll take about
up to three months to get planning
so that's that's the thing about it
however what we're planning to do is
gonna be a hmo so we're going to start
the building work up to what we know we
can get planning for and then the other
stuff we will wait until we get the
license
so we bought this house for 170 000
pounds
next door
is being sold i think it's just had
it's just been sold suddenly to contract
for 220 000 pounds
now
the main reason why i wanted to buy this
property because you've got so much
potential i can convey to flats i can
convey to um you know a massive hmo i
can convert to another pat hotel
because the square footage on here it's
almost one foot more than next door so
it's got so much potential and it needs
a bit of work yes it's a bit rough but
as a property investor the rougher it
looks is the more that we want it so
that's the amazing thing about profits
investing
[Music]
man i'm excited man i'm super excited
for what the future entails um you know
being creative in property as an
entrepreneur is one thing but actually
investing and actually owning an asset
is completely different and i'm just
super pumped that proves to me it proves
to everyone around me that i am capable
of doing it so i know the future is
bright
never stop believing guys never stop
believing
yeah so just here collecting the kids
and viewing the property just about to
go in someone has invited me to come
down and share my story on stage today
so just heading to the event right now
in manchester to have a quick piece on
stage so the stage is a little bit flat
you ready let's do it
all good yes
all
and the prize is going to be a financial
freedom challenge but you will have to
eat [ __ ] for a whole month
and i'll you'll be on video you might
look silly and you'll be doing
challenges or whatever uh he said that's
amazing i was like here's the
application form go and apply he applied
he got accepted he came to my house
did some exercises and they did the
eviction
i'll come i'll come to each of your
houses and i'll spend a week with each
of you and then they're all blown away
he came on the hatchimal boot camp
he went through the train and then the
following week i spent a week with him
and in that week he became completely
financially free just because i spent
that wee with them i gave a week of my
life
and uh evans has actually gone on to
become a good friend and evans is on his
way to becoming a millionaire
and this morning just this morning i've
picked up the keys to one of his latest
properties he's attempted hmm in keely
and it's just such a pleasure and i i
thought i'd give you a trick at this
special manchester
united revolution and i thought it might
be uh you know evan evans said to me
said sammy said um i've become
financially free i'm on my way to
becoming a millionaire i'm making like
fifteen thousand pounds a month my life
has completely changed he said but you
know what i think it'd be really i think
it'd be really powerful and i think it
would really help people if i was able
to share some of my top lessons in the
last year and how i've done what i've
done so
we we uh we never had a conversation and
i agreed that evans could come down to
the regular revolution in manchester and
share with you some some notes if if
you're open yeah all right so
i want you to go crazy in fact um you
know
as i say evidence is one of the most i
mean evans used to live in the caribbean
and his job was used to like sell fish
and stuff make a few pounds a month he's
gone from nothing
and when i went to the first viewing
with evans
on the financial freedom challenge evans
is black
he's a black guy from um
from the caribbean and on his first
viewing
when we got there the lady wouldn't let
him in the house because of the color of
his skin
you know now listen
i mean
um
it's a sensitive subject but
i don't mean to go on about race or
anything and i know everyone's got
different perspectives i'm married to a
black lady but i i first hand saw
evan's going through real struggles and
hardships
and he's fallen through it and he's
pushed through
and now he's close to being a
millionaire but he's making 15 right at
the moment starting with nothing so when
evans comes up i just want you to show
him some uh some honor so can we come
and be upstanding for my good friend
mr evans
literally it was october 25th last year
when i sat down in the seamlessness of
you guys
taking a look at you know this
opportunity for the first time
and at the time i was jack of all trades
master of night i was doing i had a
full-time job
i was doing a bit of trading um i had my
si license that was going to be a
security you know open doors
and
at the time i came down and i sat down
and i heard something was good for the
first time
and i was just so moved man i was just
so pumped
and
i actually said to myself you know one
day
i'm gonna be one of your success
students man one day i'm gonna be on
stage and i'm gonna share my story um
and one day is the day guys one day
i mean just imagine right
just imagine that you're going to a bar
right and you see this haughty man this
girl's at the bar and uh you know you
approach this girl and she's you know
she's a little bit thick believe me in
the summer
and
um oh my god you're so beautiful
how many months pregnant are you
can you agree guys by erase the balance
that her right hand is going to end up
on your body elections by subway
shipping phone can you agree with that
yeah now can you agree that it doesn't
matter how many bars you go to how many
different cities how many different
countries it doesn't matter what
language the girl speaks as long as
you're telling her about she's gonna how
many months is due because it's not
so that's the reason why when you come
to the trade a lot of people say go for
no you can go for more as much as you
want but if you send the wrong things to
the agent or the landlord you're never
going to get a deal
so for those of you coming to the trade
you're going to learn the exact menu the
exact recipe that i learned the exact
word about what to say
even if my caribbean accent can get
built if you learn those terminology and
rent around you're going to kill it
what do you have to do
copy and paste
this is me you have to copy and paste
guys one of the quickest ways of me
getting hey just copying and pasting
your list copying and pasting ricky i
haven't copy and paste them so much i
copied it a copy and pasted the way that
they work
you know when you're jewelry because
jewelry when i met
[Music]
and those that don't do anything and
complain is
the right knowledge the right level of
belief copying and pasting and taking
action and that in closing all i want to
say is i really want to thank you guys
for taking the opportunity to listen to
me and listen to my story i really
appreciate each and everybody
[Music]
[Music]
good job thanks for doing that
i think
well done big respect
[Music]
so it's been an absolutely phenomenal
day we collected the keys to our first
you know hmo first of all
and how did i do on stage right
to becoming property millionaires
[Music]